and for now the Saints heading to
Seattle this weekend they stayed out on
the west coast they played the Rams this
past Sunday Drew Brees had surgery on
Wednesday to repair the torn ligament in
his thumb so who will the quarterback be
for the New Orleans Saints well Sean
Payton not willing to name a starter
making it clear he is going to use both
options at his disposal Teddy
Bridgewater and Taysom Hill and I like
this right it makes sense use them both
you use Taysom Hill when Drew Brees is
there you may as well use Taysom Hill
and probably even more extensively when
Teddy Bridgewater is there and you put
pressure on the defense Kris to be ready
for both guys and I think this is gonna
be a potentially intriguing package and
maybe a glimpse of the future as soon as
2020 life after Drew Brees
Sean Payton getting a taste of it now
yeah I mean I'm excited to see how he
uses this I mean it doesn't really
matter it doesn't sound like as far as
who starts the football game you know I
guess I can understand starting Teddy
Bridgewater he of course has starting
experience in environments like this he
wouldn't be overwhelmed this would be
tasting he'll making his first start and
one of the loudest like craziest
stadiums in all of football so I could
see that being maybe the biggest concern
for a guy like John Payton but Mike I'll
say it I've been saying it on my podcast
I think I said it yesterday I can't
remember because I talked so much but I
still think Taysom Hill is the guy that
gives this team the offense their
highest ceiling especially these next
two weeks with Seattle and Dallas
Cowboys on the on the schedule you know
Teddy Bridgewater we know what he is at
this point he's a game manager they're
gonna run the the Drew Brees offense but
it's gonna be a little less than version
where Taysom Hill I think gives the
defensive coordinator a lot to think
about because of different packages and
wrinkles you can throw at him let alone
the physical ability with the big arm
and the running and the scrambling that
he can make the plays off schedule - and
that's where I really love to taste some
Hill advantage and then you've got the
mad scientist who is Sean Payton coming
up with various plays aimed at creating
opportunities where guys are wide open
and Taysom Hill or Teddy Bridgewater can
throw the ball and there's the touchdown
there's the first down there's the
sustaining play that Sean Payton is so
well known for coming up with and he's
constantly studying and searching and
thinking about ways to make that offense
better and to find those mismatches
based upon the specific matchup they
have and one last point right this is
the first time Teddy Bridgewater and the
Seahawks have gotten together since the
Blair Walsh game right so the the
Seahawks know what Teddy Bridgewater can
do now that was before Teddy
Bridgewater's knee injury but with the
game on the line
Teddy Bridgewater against that Seahawks
defense moved the ball down the field
and got the Vikings in position for what
would have been down winning field goal
but for Blair Walsh
so yeah the the Seahawks I think they're
gonna have their hands full and and I
think anybody who just thinks the Saints
are gonna tread water between now and
the time drew drew drew Brees comes back
they haven't been paying close attention
to the Saints in recent years they
haven't had to get by without Drew Brees
but I think that Sean Payton will be
able to hold it together until Brees
comes back and create wouldn't talk
about a timeline for Brees return six
weeks is the number that's been out
there but Chris you know I think I think
that they they weather this storm and
they'll still be in position to be
relevant in their division because it's
not like their division is great no the
division is not great I think that's the
biggest point you're spot on there and
again let's just not forget that New
Orleans is a talented football team they
match up well with a team like Seattle
Seattle wants to run the ball New
Orleans run defense will be one of the
better better ones in football it was
last year they're phenomenal up front so
they're gonna be accustomed to play in
this physical style football you know
let's not forget New Orleans went into
Baltimore last week last year and won
that game and kind of played like a lot
of taste some Hill power run football so
that's where I expect the Saints to kind
of change their MO a little bit it'll be
more creative with the run game in
general we'll taste some hill design
runs at all that but I'm with you Mike
the Saints ain't going down without a
fight and I think they will weather this
storm and I still think they're gonna go
to the playoffs even without Drew Brees
for the next five to six weeks yeah you
know I had them not making it to the
playoffs before the season started so
it's not like I'm gonna change my mind
at this point but I'm not ready to write
them off especially because of the
struggles of the other teams in their
division
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports